Jean-Luc Godard c'est un auteur
réalisateur marquant de toute l'histoire
du cinéma mondial parce que la Nouvelle
Vague française c'est lui qui l'a lancé
en collaboration avec François Truffaut
bien sûr mais la politique des auteurs
réalisateurs c'est vraiment lui qui l'a
le plus pleinement incarné la carrière
de Jean-Luc Godard en gros c'est deux
temps d'abord une montée fulgurante
pendant 6 environ entre 1959 date du
premier film à bout de souffle jusqu'à
1965 date de Pirou le fou et puis
ensuite après cette montée fulgurante et
bien ça va être une langue descente
progressive de plus en plus solitaire
d'abord pourquoi cette montée fulgurante
et bien d'abord parce que Jean-Luc
Godard est un formidable innovateur avec
à bout de souffle il a notamment créé
des effets qu'on n'avait jamais vu
jusque là dans le monde de l'écriture
cinématographique par ailleurs le
langage qui est assez familier c'est
rare qu'on entend des mots comme
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire dégueulasse
ça c'est des mots qu'on entendait
absolument jamais dans le cinéma dit de
papa le cinéma traditionnel avec bande à
part en 1964 Jean-Luc Godard innove
encore en déconstruisant le scénario et
en occultant dans une histoire de casse
toute la partie braquage c'est-à-dire la
seule chose qui intéresse vraiment les
gens et cette originalité
Tarantino lui-même va s'en servir avec
son film réservoir dogs donc des
disciples godards il en a eu des tonnes
Jean-Luc Godard donc c'est un géant au
pied d'argile parce que progressivement
il va se couper je dirais du public et
c'est vrai Jean-Luc Godard n'est pas un
cinéaste bankable c'est-à-dire que
beaucoup de gens voient les films de
bonheur mais jamais ou rarement il paye
pour aller les voir et Jean-Luc Godard
progressivement a fait des films qui ont
moins en moins bien marché donc au bout
du compte Jean-Louis Godard il a
développé les formes du cinéma il a créé
des télescopages audiovisuels il a été
vraiment un grand innovateur et puis la
dernière chose auquel il faut rendre
hommage c'est l'extraordinaire penseur
du cinéma que Jean-Luc Godard en fait
Jean-Luc Godard c'est un intellectuel
insérébral improbablement un grand
littéraire qui a fait du cinéma un peu
par accident ça l'a donné une notoriété
mais là ce qu'il aimait c'est penser le
cinéma il a
une parole un peu prophétique il a dit
j'attends la fin du cinéma avec
optimisme c'est un bel exemple de cette
ironie qu'il avait constamment il était
conscient que le cinéma était très
fragile il est il aimait le cinéma mais
il aimait surtout réfléchir sur le
cinéma et au bout du compte on pourrait
dire qu'aujourd'hui on peut attendre la
reconnaissance de Jean-Luc Godard avec
optimiste parce que vraiment il a marqué
le cinéma
[Musique]
solide et insolite
beau comme tout